At Udacity, we're doing something very special.
We're launching the world's first comprehensive
program on Artificial Intelligence.
As you know, Udacity, over the years, has
taught many millions of students many different
things, but no field is as active as artificial
intelligence.
It ranges from deep learning to robotics to
computer vision, even natural language processing
to build the next Amazon Alexa.
Today we're launching the School of AI, which
is a comprehensive program of many different
Nanodegree programs.
The New York Times recently said, there's
only about 10,000 people in the world that
are AI experts and employable in the field,
but there's more than 10,000 open positions
here in silicon valley alone.
So enroll today, become an AI expert, and
join us in this ongoing revolution to make
the world a better place with AI.